c'est l'application qui buzz en ce
moment sur la toile en effet
l'application fait simplement de
l'anglais visage application base sur la
toile
tu as déjà dit ça oui les amis bonjour
l'accent ça va bonjour aujourd'hui on va
jouer un jeu le but c'est de faire du
bruit pour ces faux j'ai cru pour les
amis vous avez dû voir ces fameux
collage de photos tous les youtuber ont
publié sur twitter y compris moi y
compris toi je les fais mais voilà je
vais tourner cette vidéo sol et maxence
on s'est vu juste avant il s'est mis à
parler de cette application est vu je
voulais faire de sûreté plication je me
suis dit mais maxence dur avec moi on
est bien dans mon bureau vient oui bon à
l'écran vous voyez nos deux visages
absolument ignobles alors déjà les gens
veulent voir qui suit ça donne quand on
le fait nous oui est expliqué le concept
non ok ça marche en gros ça vous donne
votre vous féminin votre vous vieux et
votre vous bébé voilà on va toi tu
sélectionnes quoi en premier parce que
j'ai vu moi je mets tout haut la main
son premier
le film est long la femmelle quoi mais
je suis un peu un alien oui mais aussi
quand même nom c'est bien c'est bien ça
tu vas tu me paies chaud tu peux
témoigner un peu se moquer et attention
le sourire moi qui sourit en quoi c'est
toujours dégueulasse c'est oui oui et
puis ça donne en si je me range à bâle
c'est vrai dit qu'est ce que tu étais
vraiment comme ces jeunes n'ont pas
assez parlé allait venir à toi tu veux
je suis sûr je suis choqué tout le
ballon fuit au cachot et il le sait ce
qu'il veut c'est qu'il est très mal en
fille alors je m'écroule la vie la vie
ouais mais est ce que c'est un truc où
il ya le plus de suspense ok ok alors le
smile le monde il était dans le vrai
dans ces bizarres jeu mais comment cela
est la fille la fille allait en vrai au
jour la fille un peu de bain mais pas
homme était qu un week end
ok et attention derrière le dernier un
tabou tabour on sait en plus on et ouais
j'ai bronzé bien plus que vous elle va
forcer sur le vin chaud rouge là sur le
marché de noël ou connais bien je
connais bien maintenant on va
télécharger des photos de gens qu'on
veut voir en fille que marquez ont fini
moi j'aimerais bien hormis story alors
ivic assez génial c'est génial jeune tu
penses ce serait une belle mort
non je savais un mec non non non non
mais je sens qu'il peut être très bon au
sahel est parfaite passé en fait si on
arrive à trouver une bonne meuf à partir
cette photo c'est que ces basses il faut
acheter fayçal du coup fait qu'il faut
acheter fait si bien sûr il tenta bien
tentative de faire un tour pierre de la
part de weiss a peut être méchant on
dirait georges en caroline s'abonner à
votre instagram tu vas te ya un clic un
rolling 12 ans passionnée d'équitation
pourquoi il fait que nemtsov ouais mec
je pense qu'il y ait le profil le rite
est trop viril était trop viril à pied
elle n'arrive pas à me choque la pinède
enfin on dirait la lectrice de star wars
un peu oui du dernier les vert et noir
c'est vrai que là l héroïne bien sûr pas
bien sûr pas du tout mais non pas du
tout aux attentes
c'est la mecque à temps plein rush
allait bientôt là dessus bien d'en
parler je dresse m j'espère que ça va
être bien
voilà voilà voilà la chose qu'on va
avoir une meuf hyper canon d'amazon la
mecque j'ai pas demandé un générateur de
mots j'ai demandé une passe elle allait
bien mais que c'est bon j'ai trouvé
c'est bon je trouve ça laid à l'exil sur
le rambo et le québécois alors pour les
bois c'est pas de lunel meilleurs voilà
un message mais des lentilles mais dès
lors dit qu'ils ont mais moi j'y reviens
vers françois fillon aggrave la deuxième
cela est bien celle là non franchement
si je pense qu'ils veulent prendre part
[Rires]
à l'étape les tu sais que mon avis et
conseils comme ajouté si je leur en
souriant ce qui sourit pas à ces fonds
devient moins à un voile a alors su il
est génial ce montage franchement fait
simple à la franchement là aussi je leur
en canon ouah mais ça marche trop bien
franchement cela il est top il fait
monsieur fillon vous êtes vraiment fait
pour environ pour faire
convertissez-vous peut-être pas les
élections vous a regagné le meilleur
montage de facebook voilà est-ce qu'on
va voir mélenchon
we have mais je suis un homme politique
ah non pas de jean luc reichmann à voile
à mélenchon c'est présence du paraître
vieux et rajeunit même costume est vieux
il paraît même plus jeune j'avais à
coeur bah je pensais que cette blague ne
fait plus rire mais non non je pense et
dit que ça marche trop bien ça marche
trop bien mais c'est le sait le même
quoi à algarve sourire que tu avais mec
mais totalement vas-y aller sous les
méchants aux îles c'est son sourire en
plus ça on s'arrête de nistos algérie là
c'est sourire là tu crois pas donc
mélenchon ce oui ça c'est sûr 68e le
matin et ça devrait te retourner tu fais
quoi
j'en fais mon fond d'écran
moi j'aimerais bien voir la salle c'est
jean lassalle îles à lamèque l'union
enfin j'aime pas j'aime pas relevé des
algues sur physique mais est ce que tu
as déjà vu un nicolas à la villa et moi
on attend ce mec alors déjà il faut
savoir envoyer genre et féline 8,2 m
lemaitre a oui mais car je garde la
campagne il est pour moi c'est un perso
genre dans le seigneur des anneaux non
tu sais les géants dans weeds
attention attention moi sur mes mecs
trop mais si oui ou non mais même s'il a
la carrure c'est le job au tce qui fait
cette taille
ah ouais c'est que l'elysée vient pas
pour l'immeuble
tu vois ouais rien par rapport à loeb
d'ailleurs c'est alors y'a qui d'autre
on veut voir qui macron peut-être je
pourrais faire ça tout l'après-midi les
genres les jours je sais pas mais nous
en tout cas on veut d'akron charmante
mignonne envieux a donc là tu vas lui
l'est pas encore vieux est ce que ces
souris peut-être m'attend c'était
incroyable lui tout marche
en fait ces deux politiques c'est leur
pouvoir tu vois leur pouvoir de
persuasion il passe partout qui ont mais
d'autres n'importe qui qui tu veux
attendent avant je me crée que la fille
vient régulièrement
ouais c'est un jeu rapide en disant non
lui ouais mais craque leno séparément
vous pouvez faire
non mais sa campagne d arthrose là par
contre maintenant c'est faux c'est faux
alors il ya un mec en fait il sait
évent malade il a reçu un prix nobel je
regarde c'est ça il sait toute sa vie
ici craqué qu'une main et pas l'autre et
gérard yvé la vieille cela est
maintenant il est vieux il a capté qui
sait demain était dans le même état
d'âme cette vidéo design extérieur je
m'en bats les couilles et donc tu as dit
la première
on verra à l'adversaire et ça y est tu
sais comment comment faire pour voir si
une pile à atur déficit est dedans tu
vas me soit monde
ouais je savais ouais moi aussi qui sait
que c'est trop naïve anvers j'aimerais
bien voir will smith au ghana est sûre
mais regardez en homme du quick smith
alors faire une version plus mal c'est
que ça marche bien à ce que la cuisse
bon bah voilà on obtient ladakh le
second du coup peut-être qu'ils devront
en tout cas rien à je veux trouver une
corrélation entre deux personnes et non
à l'indien côté rigole assis à côté des
glaçons oui on me dit son [ __ ] mais
encore fois kad merad et kad merad
caméra s il rajeunit kad merad jour
direct alors kad merad je plaisantais un
stimulant à ces thèmes là une totale ben
non moi je trouve à 820 kad merad ah non
abbas et que toutes mes yeux je ressens
la semaine la plus jeune et la retient
maxence un bébé mort et six de leurs
empreintes laissées il a essayé de
recoller des cheveux tant bien que mal à
les accalmies d'y aller quand même la
cua ailleurs plan mais je tu veux pas
contesté le joint une grimace on vous
allez on a un retour à huy j'ai un truc
à faire marquer regardez les gens tu as
vu une montagne sur la gauche et magali
magail assure m avec ses crises des
dettes par hasard mais derrière moi en
tant que vrai ouais je suis prêt je n'ai
pas envie de la voir je n'assume pas
dans tout ça à l'image là l'apli a
planté là même grimace mais s'il me
plaît donnez la sacema grimace fiable
que je fabrique mes yeux je pense que ça
marche et y'a moyen je vois quand même
belle en vrai puisque c'est symétrique
ouais franchement ouais non mais tu peux
penser de meuf qui te
reprieve avait des tentes est-ce qu'on
va avoir une figurine étape attend à
trois graves
that is young l'héroïne direct c'est
raciste
oui non je te disais un jour foutu tente
un faisceau avec un jet à huy moscou
[Musique]
c'est la plus belle chose que j'ai vu de
ma vie j'ai voyagé j'en ai vu des choses
mais ça ht facebook j'étais tout jeter
tout bon les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo tout est parti en couille est
parti en squeez mes mecs je crois que en
six ans j'ai jamais autant j'ai pas plus
que j'en ai chialé meriem pour le jackie
chan n'hésitez pas et même de ça vous a
pris merci parce qu'il est passé de
taper des barres à l'infini c'était
hyper drôle on sortait d'une prochaine
et aussi vous a donné une idée pour une
future vidéo
on va peut-être faire peut-être que dans
dix minutes on sera plus à froid on va
dire mais c'était une autre idée de
feutre on n'est pas la faute plein de
bijoux à traîneau via google
n'hésitez pas à passer par la chaîne de
maxence le lien dans la description il
fait des vidéos hyper coup chaque
semaine tu t'avances la tête en sang
arrête de suite avant ça mais oui oui
at-elle enchaîné à partir de nature tout
beau et voter jean la fête
[Musique]